これは これはあんまり難しくない
カーマ・ウパーダーナね
カーマ あとはディッティ・シーラ・ブッダ
この四つなんですね テキストではウパーダーナということを繋げているんだから
ちょっと読みにくいかもしれません
カーマ・ディッティ・シーラ・ブッダというウパーダーナが四つあるんです
ウパーダーナというのは個人が捕まっているんですね
個習と書いてますけどね
カーマは欲 欲といったって五欲の方が多いんですね
眼耳鼻舌身から刺激いただきますと
刺激欲しいんだから それなくなったら死ぬかもしれませんと
怖くなっちゃって 誰もね
例えば面白いことものを見るのをやめましょうと言ったら
すごく怖くなっちゃうんです
美しい音を聞くのをやめようと思ったら
冗談じゃないんだと 面白くないんだ
それなくなったら生きる意味なくなっちゃうんだという風に言っちゃうんですね
美味しいものを食べるのをやめましょうと
それはもう冗談じゃないと
やっぱりその五欲ですか
眼耳鼻舌身から刺激を得ようとしていて
眼耳鼻舌身に対象 色受想行名色
それは捕まってるんですね
捕まって もっとより綺麗な色を探す
より綺麗な声を探す より綺麗な美味しい味を探すというふうなことになっちゃうんですね
だから生命というのは
そういう生きるために自分でその欲に欲を捕まって
それに命繋げているんです
だから解脱できないんです
捨てられないんだから
この原因は本人にあるんですね
この場合は カーマっていうのは
あの あの 新書の場合は貪
むさぼりですね 漏婆ですね
ディッティは見ですね
でディッティ ディッティっていうのは
この やっぱり無常がわからないということで
あの 見るものはあるように見えるでしょ
壁があるんだと 音を聞いたら音があるんだと思っちゃうでしょうに
本当は音がないんです
瞬間瞬間この音という刺激が耳に触れるだけで
それは触れて消えて触れて消えてはいくでしょうに
そこで 1 秒間触れたことをまとめて
あ 音だと あ 音楽だと決めるでしょう
ですから 我々には無常見えない
壁が見たら壁があるんじゃないの
壁があるかないかなくて
壁からずっと情報がもう強烈な速さで目に触れるだけなんですね
触れたものをまとめてある
ある時間の情報をまとめて壁だと認識するんだから
そこで無常が知らないんだから
ものがあると思ってるんです
存在しているんだと ですから見邪見なんですね
本当は音楽だということも邪見なんです
今日は寒いんだ それ全部邪見なんです
この場所は目白ですよ
で言ったっても邪見なんですよ
ですから もうこれは眼耳鼻舌身から情報を取っていっていることだから
眼耳鼻舌身から来るのはもう自体間違ってるんだから
これどうしようもない
で 我々はそれと捕まってるんですね
例えば目から見る情報
綺麗だ 綺麗じゃないと決めちゃったところで
綺麗なものは並んで探して選んでいろいろ活動している
それで悟りの世界とは違うんですね
ディッティ 見 シーラ・ブッダというのは説明したこと
前 戒律やら行に囚われる
戒律はいいんだ 行はいいんだと
何か行いをすれば まあそれで悟るんだと
それで心は軽くなるんだと
それはかっこいいんだという自分で好むで好むんだから
それで理性的な人間にならないでしょ
戒律 戒と行に囚われたら
あれは合理的じゃないんだからね
滝行をやったらなぜ心が清らかになるか
沐浴すればなぜ心が清らかになるかという
全然合理的なことじゃないでしょうに
大目講を唱えればなぜ幸福になるかと
なぜ家庭円満安全になる
家庭安全というんですか
家内安全になるかと よく言うでしょうね
家内安全 じゃあ大目講を 1 日 1,000回ぐらいだけも唱えなさい
家内安全じゃなくて この 1 日 1,000回大目講を唱えて亡くなる時間でさらにひどくなる恐れがありますけどもね
そんな時間があるならば掃除でもすればいいのに
もっと数一つぶやればね
子供たちの料理にいいのにね
それだったら家内安全ですけど
やっぱりそういういろいろ開花
行果にはいいと本人が捕まってるんだからウパーダーナと呼ぶんです
それ捕まったら理性で失う
理性を失ったらもう悟りはなくなっちゃう
どうせ行をやる限りはね
無常はわからないんだからね
で 4番目はアッターワーダ
アッターワーダっていうのは魂のこと
我のこと 自我のこと 私に私がいるんだという概念なんですね
そこも本人がそう思ってるだけで
例えば音が入るでしょ
音っていうのは瞬間瞬間変化するということは誰でも頭ではわかってるし
で  1 秒間音が聞いたら私が聞いたと本人が思うんですね
そこで私が現れるんです
聞いたということじゃなくて
1 秒間の大量の色 生滅変化した色
大量の色をまとめて音というだけであって
それは正真正銘の妄想という妄想であって
その妄想に基づいて私が聞きましたと
まず大量の音が入る 音という生滅変化する物質が耳に入る
この大量をまとめて音と認識する
いわゆる音楽だ 人の声だと認識する
それはもう幻覚の世界
それでその あ これ聞いたのは私ですよとさらに考えちゃう
そこら辺は自我 アッマンの世界
そこで実体がある 私がいるという巨大妄想が生まれるんですね
ですから それは人間には当然
人間がそういう巨大妄想を作るんであって
で 悟る 瞑想しなきゃそれわからないんですね
そこに音がないんだと
音楽っていうものはないんだ
単なる音と音っていう
ほんの瞬間瞬間触れるだけであって
その触れるものはこちらで判断するんだと
音と音して それは恐ろしい速さで起こるんだから
我々には自我でないことはわからないんだ
そこで自我が生まれるんだ
そこで自我という幻覚が生まれるんだ
幻覚でも本人にとっては実体で見られます
例えば瞑想すると幻覚現れるでしょ？実際にないもの
でも瞑想する人にとっては実際に見えます
見えたり聞こえたりするんだから
だから幻覚だといって軽く捨てるわけでもいきませんし
難しいしね だから自我っていうことは
魂がある 私がいるということは
我々にとっては実感なんです
でも それは幻想なんですね
幻覚なんですね で それはアッタ・バードと言うんですね
それも私が自分がいると思ってるんだから
固執と言うんです 自分でそういうふうに思っている
ハイリスワラ ギョワラ
素晴らしいと自分がそう思っている
この無常が見えないことも私がそう思ってるんですね
音がある 人がいるとかね
欲も私が欲を負っているんですね
それそこに組織的な働きではないんですね
まあそちらの因果法則から見れば組織なんですけど
前とは違う でも真相は同じなんですね
前も欲がありましたし
見がありましたしね でも今の場合は違う働き
心理学的に違う働きを見て
ここが何かなにか捕まって
輪廻転生 輪廻脱出しないように輪廻にしがみついていくと
それから苦しみが生れると
それはウパーダーナの要素
で ウパーダーナは修行によってどんどん捨てることはできます
あの組織は もう生まれないように最初からしなくちゃいけない
前説明したものカーヤ・ガンタ
四つありましたね アビッジャー・カーヤ・ガンタ
ヴィーアーパダ・カーヤ・ガンタ
それからイダン・ジャナプテ
シーラッブタ・バーラーマサ・カーヤ・ガンタ
イダン・サッチャーディ・ニヴェーサ・カーヤ・ガンタ
それはもう修行なくても
もうその組織が生まれないようにするのはできます
生まれたらすぐそれやめればいいんです
で ウパーダーナの場合は私が捕まってるんだから
私に見える幻覚だから幻覚で
幻覚ですよとわからなきゃダメなんですね
ですから これはちょっと修行によってなくさなくちゃいけないことなんです
あ わかった 今日からはウパーダーナ
固執しませんよと言ったって
それは嘘です でも今日からはカーヤ・ガンタしませんよと言ったら
それは努力はできます
同じ欲なんですけど カーヤ・ガンタにはならないようにするはできます
可能です でもウパーダーナにならないようにするのは
それはもう無理ですね
それは修行の結果でなくなります
次 次はニーヴァーナ ニーヴァーナ
ニーヴァーナっていうのは蓋という意味なんですね
蓋 蓋閉めてると心に それはアビダンマでは六つですね
普通はニーヴァーナは五つなんです
アビダンマでは六つにしているんです
カーマ・チャンダ うん？スライド抜けちゃった
次行っちゃう 抜けちゃった
そういう蓋がアビダンマでは六つ
お経では五つ 抜けるのはアヴィッジャですね
アヴィッジャ取っちゃえば五つです
お経の方が覚えておけばいいんです
お経の方が古いんですからね
で 身悪なというのは蓋
心にちょっと野菜なんか漬物にする
重りするような もう逃げないように蓋をかけておくんですね
だから心を抑えられているんです
自由にならないように
ですからそれも修行によって捨てることも必要であるし
自分でも努力する必要あるんですね
修行によって綺麗に一つ一つ蓋をね
壁を破られる場合もありますけど
やっぱり自分でもそれなりに努力しなくちゃいけないんです
カーマ・チャンダっていうのは前言ったカーマは同じことなんです
もうチャンダという言葉をつけて
チャンダっていうのは好きということでね
カーマが好きですよということで
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身の対象
色声香味触 それは欲しいですよと
例えば瞑想すると 美味しい何かご飯食べたいなとかね
早く終わってテレビを見たいなとかね
そういうふうに早く終わったら早く寝たいなとかね
そういうふうな気持ちが出てくるでしょうし
で それはもうカーマ チャンダなんですね
違うことをやりたいと
それで そういう気持ちがある限りは禅定も悟りも出てこない
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身に捕らわれている限りは
眼耳鼻舌身を超えることは不可能で当たり前のことなんです
目に見えるものに捕まって捕らわれている限りは
その次元を超えることはできないんですね
ですからカーマ・チャンダは涅槃を
涅槃できないように 禅定もできないように
心は成長しないように
我々に蓋をかけている
ヴェーパーダっていうのは怒り
怒りっていうのはまた同じ眼耳鼻舌身に対するものなんですね
物と心のごとうで ものを見たら嫌ですよと思っちゃうと
それに捕らわれてるんですね
私はあの人を嫌いですよというと
自分がその人に捕らわれてるでしょうに
関わりがあるでしょうに
全く関わりない人に対しては嫌いでも好きでも何でもないんだから
関わりがないんだから
だから私はあの人を嫌いですよという場合も
あの人を好きですよという場合も同じ
その人に対しては関わりがあるんです
ですからヴェーパーダということは
やっぱり即席に関わりがあるということ
怒り それは怒りの真相
ウッダッチア・クックッチア
ウッダッチアっていうのは混乱状態ですね
落ち着いてない状態  [咳]なんか落ち着きがない状態
心にあるね イライラでもないんだけど
なんか落ち着きがない
ずっと落ち着いて冷静にいられない心の状態
昔の例えは このハエに何か石を投げたような感じで
ハエが飛び上がっちゃうんですね
そんな感じで 心はもうなんか散乱状態になってるんですね
クックッチャってのは後悔
それはもう過去に惹かれることなんですね
いいことをできなかったとかね
悪いことをしてしまったとかね
例えば今日は瞑想うまくいかなかったって
これ後悔なんですね 悪い罪なんですね
怒りに入るんです これね
だから瞑想しながら怒りを繁殖しちゃうとかね
それで怒りをなくそうと
またもうやりきれないことなんですけど
言うのは僕はもうどれほど言ってるかといっても
やっぱり心っていうのはなかなか理解しないんですね
判断してはいけないとね
うまくいったとか うまくいかなかったとか言うなとね
そんなことはね うまくいったと思ったら自分で威張ることであってね
それは欲を繁殖したことになっちゃうし
今日はうまくいかなかったらこれ後悔であって
怒りの罪であるしね だから煩悩ばっかし繁殖して煩悩をなくしますよと
ちょっとありえない話で
だから本当のヴィパッサナーというのは
やり方次第 簡単だからといって
システム次第ではもうこの世の中で何よりもものすごい複雑にできているんです
で これはクックッチャ
後悔 ヴィチキッチャっていうのは疑いですね
疑いっていうのは心はしっかりしないという状態で
知ろうとしない状態なんですね
だからわからない 知識的な疑いがある
本当にあんた言ってること本当かなと
そのヴィチキッチャじゃないんです
調べてみようという人が調べるでしょうね
それは仏教では別に問題ないんです
この 何て言いますか 知識的な疑いというかね
他の言葉ないんだけどね
こちらで言えば 私はあまり信じませんとね
嘘でしょ そんなことは
そんな感じの すごい軽々と
で 平気で言って 我々はもう怠けちゃう
だからこれは知識的な怠けと現代訳したってもいいんです
知識的な怠けだと 普通精神的な怠けじゃないんです
5番目はティーナ・ミンテ
ティーナ・ミンテは昏睡ですね
で 昏睡というのは心の状態なんですね
心が昏睡状態が作っちゃったら
それは昏睡という心所なんですね
回転しないんですね 元気じゃない
病気なんですね ですから昏睡も解脱と禅定も瞑想も抑えつける
蓋をかけちゃう  6番目はアヴィッジャー
アヴィッジャーっていうのは無明
それは前にあった見なんですね
前の 4つで出てきた見と同じこと
前出てきた見じゃなくて
ウパーダーンの時ね 五取の場合はディッティ・ウパーダーンが出たんですね
あれと同じことなんですね
ディッティなんですね
無明と言ったっても まあでも無明という
アビダンマとしてもそれ入れちゃって困っちゃいますけどね
無明という心所はないしね
妄想はありますけど ですから
経に基づくとアヴィッジャーっていうのは見という心所なんです
アビダンマに基づくとアヴィッジャーっていうのは無知という妄想の心相なんですね
繋げているんだから問題はないんだけどね
経典ではアヴィッジャーという無明という言葉を大事に使ってあって
アヴィッジャーって何ですかというと
全ては無常であって 現象であるということはわからないという状態
頑張らなきゃ理解できない状態ですから
すべての生命は本来持ってるんですね
それで悟れなくなっちゃうんです
ですからアヴィッジャが消えたら
もう全部悟ってしまっちゃうんです
アヴィッジャ消すにしても
この上の人々が邪魔するんですね
上の心性がね ゲンニビセッシンネ
大将が好きであるし 怒っちゃうし
ああだこうだとかいろいろトラブルがあるんだから
混乱するし 後悔するし
そういうややこしいことでまた邪魔になっちゃう
ですから この蓋の場合は五蓋あるいは六蓋の場合は瞑想によっても消えるということはあります
そこで出てきたら瞑想はできなくなっちゃう
ですから両方で頑張らなくちゃいけない
瞑想で頑張るとどんどん消えてはいくんだけど
瞑想するためにこれは最初からは抑えておかなくちゃいけないし
欲望はもういいですよと
もうやめますと 修行中はもう怒りませんと
昏沈睡眠 なんとか頑張って出てこないようにすると
それにして修行すると
そうするとそれは機能しなくなる
それで修行を進めるとさらに機能しなくなって消えていっちゃうんです
後で 消えていっちゃったらすごい元気になっちゃう
元気になったらすぐその場で禅定も生まれるし
悟りの境地にも入ることができます
そういうふうに涅槃という状態
人の心に智慧が現れる状態は蓋を隠しているというならば
蓋という言葉を使うならば六つありますと
固執と言葉使えば四つあるんだと
苦悲喜というならば四つあるんだと
そういうふうに明確に心の働き分けてます
次にアヌセー 七つ だからこの章が終わったら
現代心理学とアビダンマはなぜ違うかとわかると思いますね
現代心理学で喋っているものは大雑把で喋ってるんだから
アビダンマはあんまりにもすごい明確に心性を分けて
それぞれの心性の働き
また違うカテゴリーに入れているんだからね
これからアヌセーというのは繊細
繊細ですかね 発音がわかりません
アヌセー七つ それはちょっと言葉変えますけど
カーマラーグ アチーチェ
これは睡眠 睡眠ですね
睡眠 寝ている 寝ていると隠れていて
我々の感じを作るんですね
だから七つの心所が心の中に隠れていて
働かないで寝ているんだけど
それでどんどん意識化したりする
そして人々の生き方を決めてしまう
心所としては全部貪瞋痴なんです
で カーマラーガって何でもわかりやすいことでしょうに
カーマっていうのは眼耳鼻舌身意の対象でしょうし
いわゆる色声香味触でしょうし
ラーガっていうのは欲ですね
だから色声香味触に対して欲
欲しいと思うこと だから貪りの貪なんですね
で バヴァラーガって何ですか
バヴァっていうのは有と書いてあると思いますけど
これは生きていきたいという気持ちなんですね
生きていきたい 涅槃はダメ
なぜならばまた生まれ変わりませんだから
どうせ死ぬんだったら天国でも生きたい
それは永遠だったらありがたいというふうには一応思ってはいるんです
そういう事実は全くないんだけど
人はそれは嘘でも信じますと
だから存在したい 生きていきたいという欲
バヴァラーガというんです
ですから それも貪瞋痴の貪
貪り 同じ心所なんですね
この場合は種類の働きを
いわゆる寝ている 生きていきたいという感情が寝ていて
我々は生かされているんです
いろんなものを見たい
聞きたい 食べたいという気持ちが寝ていて
この本能としていて どうしてもやらざるを得ない状態になっちゃうんですね
パティグハは怒り 怒りももう寝ていて
時々現れる マーナはマーナという心所ですから
それは自分というものを現象
幻覚を作って 自分と他人を比べること
その比べるならば そこでもう悟りは現れない
もう完全な悟りはもうほとんど不可能なんです
なぜならば 測るために
比べるために 自分がいなかったらできないでしょうに
昔風な秤ありますね 両側入れる一つの側に重さのものを入れて
品物はそちら違う方に入れて
それで測ってみるでしょうに
それ一つだけ入れて測れませんでしょうに
ですからマーナ 測ることのためには自分がいるという感覚が必要なんです
ですから あの人より私は優れている
あの人と似ている あの人より私は頑張っているとかね
いつでもそういう考え方でしょう
世の中っていうのは だから経済学的な話になると
いつでもチャートが出て
チャートが出て比べる比べる測る測るだけでしょうね
ですから それは我々精神的にもやってるんですね
なんだかんだあの人より私は綺麗
あるいはあの人は私よりは綺麗とか
あの人は私よりは頭がいいとか
私の方が頭がいいとか
そういうのは全部測る
その測るためには私がいるという幻覚が必要なんです
で 普段測らなくても私がいるという実感があると
ついそれ目が覚めて測ってしまう
ディッティっていうのは前ご説明しましたね
見ですね いわゆる物は存在している
実体があるんだという邪見ですね
それも隠れているんです
普段は 隠れている状態
そこで例えば地震があって
自分の誰かが うちの身内が死んじゃったと
今まで天国のことも 阿弥陀さんのことも何もいるかもしれなかった
もうそんな宗教はあるかとも知らない人々が
突然地震があって 自分の身内が死んじゃったら
やっぱり阿弥陀様のところに行ったんだからと現れるんです
煩悩が その時 だからいいんじゃないかと
それを自分を慰める あるいはもうバカなことで慰めることだからね
それはもうがん患者さんにまあまあちょっとしたもうお腹がちょっと悪いだけでね
もうあんたもういろいろもう食べ過ぎ飲み過ぎだからね
まあ今日から気をつけなさい
問題ないと言ったっても
ガンだから死んじゃいますでしょうし
ああそう まあよかったよかった
元気で というふうに人が元気で帰るかもしれませんだけど
実はガンであっても  3ヶ月とか死ぬかもしれません
嘘で慰めたってもね 結果としてはいい結果にはならないんですね
ですから このディッティっていうのは
この隠れているディッティが何かあったら現れてきて
もう輪廻を正当化する
ミチキッチャっていうのは
また前も説明した疑いですね
精神的な怠け それも結構隠れているんです
時々知りたい 知りたいと本読みたいとかあるんだけど
つい まあいいやと となりますからね
アヴィッジャっていうのは仏教で言ってる無明ですね
これは心性で言えば無知
これは見 これは疑い これは慢
これは怒り その 2つは貪り
そこでこの潜在能力やら潜在的なもうああだこうだとかね
まあフロイトよりはユングの方ですかね
まあよく喋っているのはね
じゃあ明確にそういう風にそんなエネルギーですよと
わかってる わかれてるかどうか
そんなこと何でもない
単なる一般的な一般論で
まあ照合無意識とかああだこうだとか照合無意識があるわけないんです
ただ似てるだけで 私も美味しいものを食べたら美味しいし
他の人も美味しいものを食べたら美味しいしね
若い時は誰でも相手を追っていくし
それを全ての潜在の無意識と照合無意識とかね
そんなものはないんです
ただ似てるだけ 例えばこの地球の状況が変わって
もう人々がすごく欲出してくると
例えばアメリカの方が最初に欲を出してくると
もう地球はみんなもう欲出し始めちゃうんです
だからみんなそんなわけじゃなくて
まあそれは誰でも同じ条件に-- 条件に入りますから
まあ同じ反応する なぜならばする反応は決まってるんです
不善心所は十四しかないんだから
それで似ているんだから
まあそこで あの そういう考え方出てきます
まあそれでも大変立派なそれなりの研究なんですけど
で 仏教でもやっぱり無意識の世界のことを仏教ではないでしょうに
心しか説明してないんです
でも心所としても この可能性があって
どうせこれなくしてないんだから
この七つをね なくしてないんだから
いつの間にか現れるんですね
ですから 人がある時は疑で行動する
ある時はすごい欲で行動する
ある時はまた慢で 高慢で
あるいは劣等感で行動するとかね
そういう風に まあぐるぐるぐるぐる感情が変わっちゃうんですね
決まってる性格があるわけじゃない
その点では だからたくさん慢ばっかし出てくると
あの人はすごい あの 高慢だとかね
我が強いんだとか言うかもしれませんだけど
そうでもなくて そういう性格あるわけじゃなくて
やっぱりあの感情がずっともう回転しているということなんです
まあ大体 あの 睡眠煩悩っていうのは
まあそれぐらいで 仏教の無意識といえばこれぐらいなんです
無意識の世界 じゃあまたいつかやりましょう
[笑い]